はぁぁ
[拍手]
小さい頃に書いた卒業文集を見てみるといつも決まって同じ職業のことを書いていまし
た
保育士です
保育園の卒園文集には大きくなったら保育士になりたいと書いていました
そして小学校4年生の時の夢学習の時も
保育士辞め道について調べていました
両親や祖父母が保育園を経営している事もあり保育士になるということ自体には
まったく抵抗ありませんでした
むしろ家族に対する漠然とした憧れから自分は保育士になるんだと心の中で勝手に
決め付けていたのかもしれません
だから幼い自分なりにピアノを習ってみたり
保育園のお手伝いをしてみたり沢山のことをやってきました
自分なりに保育士になるための努力をしていたんです
でもなんだか保育シーンを目指すだけじゃ満足できませんでした
なんだかもの座れなかったんです
だから小学校の時は習い事を6つ掛け持ちしてみたり
自動化に自ら立候補してみたり中学受験をやってみたり
本当にいろんなことに挑戦してきました
たぶんきっと自分にハマる何かを探していたんだと思います
そしてそんな私が今所属している部活は
科学部です
そして不思議なことに物理の研究をやっているんです
これは私が研究発表で使った資料の一部です
これを見てわかる方いらっしゃいますか
顧問の先生ですねそうですほとんどの方がわからないと思います
しかもまあマジかよってなりますよね
私も最初はそうでしたでも物理半に入った時からこんなことが当たり前になって気づか
ないうちに非常になってくるんです
さて皆さんは
物理 physics に対してどんなイメージを抱いていますか
例えばメガネ率が高いとか話が通じないとか
と同じ本を読んでいるとかオタクみたいな人が多いとか
そんなイメージだいていませんか
私し私自身も勝手にそんなイメージを抱いていました
物理をされていらっしゃる方が5枚いたらごめんなさい
でも
本当に私はこんなイメージを抱いていたんです
でも私は小さい時から憧れていた保育士とは全く違う
カークの道に足を踏み入れる踏み入れることになりました
阿蘇してしまたで裕理恵助
という道を切り開くための起爆剤にラッキーなことにも出会うことができたんです
今ラッキーという言葉を使いました
科学に出会うってラッキーだと思いませんか
思いませんか
多分それはきっとその世界にまだ目を向けたことがないからです
私は中学校に入ったときに
今まで以上にいろんなことに挑戦しようと思いました
だからもともと興味があった社会福祉系のボランティアをやってみたり
生徒会に入ってみたり本当に小学生の時とは比べ物にならないくらいもっともっと挑戦
をしていったんです
だから時にはパンクしそうになる時もあって中学校の三者面談ではいつもそろそろ優先
順位を決めなさい
早くやりたいことを見つけなさいって言われてました
でも毎日が充実したんです
毎日が本当に楽しかったんです
そんなある中学校3年生の時の夏先生からこんな提案がありました
成松高校の化学部の大会に同行してもみないか
私書道部
しかもバリバリの文系なんですけど
そんな私が各部の大会に
もちろん s ですよね
こんな性格ですから脳っていう考えなんかもともと頭になかったですし
そんな美味しい話があるのになんで行かないんだって感じで
もちろん二つ返事で ok しました
そしてある大会に参加することになったんですがこの大会が私の中に科学という新しい
視点をくれることになったんです
私が通っている学校は重厚一貫校です
でも私は高校の先輩がカークの研究をしていること自体全く知りませんでした
6しましてあ
カークのその研究の内容なんて本当にさっぱりでした
でもやっぱり部数々室に行ってみると周りを見てみればやっぱりメガネリスは高いし
振り返ってみたらずーっと同じ本ばっかり読んで先輩もいるんですね
でも案外イメージと違うところがあったんですよ
それは先輩たちがおしゃべりが大好きだったことです
中学生の私にも気さくにお話をかけてくれました
そしてある先輩は大会解除となる大阪駅の新幹線の中で私たちのために
超短期研究集中講座っていうのを開いてくれて何もわからない私たちにゼロから研究の
内容や自分の経験についてすごく情熱的な
してくれたんです
そんな姿を見たとき私は驚きにもに大感動を覚えました
こんな先輩科学部にいるんだってでも先輩たちの姿はこんなもんじゃなかったんです
大会最終日私たちの研究は
何千人ものそしてお客さんがいるステージの前で発表することになりました
そしてある先輩が研究の研究発表の最後にこう言ったんです
私たちはこの研究を教科書にのせたいです
ん
ちょっと考えてみてもやっぱりんになるんですよね
いやや先輩それビッグマウスすぎません完全
なんかえいやありえないでしょ
で単純にそう思ったんです
中学生の私なりに先輩方の研究はすごいということは分かっているつもりでした
でも高校生の研究が教科書に載るなんて想像したこともなかったですし
頭にまったくなかったんです
でも私はこのたった一言あの時のこの一言に突き動かされてこの日科学部に入部する
ことを決めました
そして今年度の物理の教科書の一ページに宇土高校科学部の研究が実際に乗ってるん
です
あの時のまさにあの時のあの一言が本当に現実のものになったんです
さてそろそろ皆さんも私はこんな風に変わった研究について研究に少し興味が湧いてき
ませんか
福実像セカンド ebm イメージ図
これが私たちの研究対象です
福実像についてご存知の方いらっしゃいますか
ほとんどいらっしゃらないですよねというのもこの服実像は
宇土高校の先輩方が初めて発見されてその時に定義したものだからです
こちらをご覧ください
これは左がどのように進むかをこうローズとして表したものです
高原から出た光が立つレンズで曲げられて反対岸実像が結像します
でもこれは中学校の範囲で習う範囲ウェイ
従来知られている実像ですしかしこれとは別にレンズの前方と後方にあと二つ現れて
いる小さな倒立像を先輩方が発見されました
そしてそれらを吹く実像と名付けられたんです
これらの服立福実像はこのように光がレンズの中に入って内部反射をすることによって
結像しています
そしてこれこそがいわゆる心霊現象を
どのように撮られているかというメカニズムを解明したり
昆虫の嘆願がどのような世界を見ているかと言うものを表す糸口になったんです
それではここで皆さんで心霊写真を撮ってみましょう
私が持っているのが平面エリーにライトですそしてこれに光をつけるとこれが高原に
なります
もし皆さんの中で携帯 iphone や xperia 持っていらっしゃる方がい
たら私のほうにカメラを向けてもらってもいいですか
なんだか肉眼では見えないけど
レンズの中に浮いている不思議な光はないですか
見つけられましたか
それこそが吹く実像です皆さんどんな像が映っていますか
くまモンの像見えますか
今回ご用意したのはくまモンの像をご用意してみました
もし携帯を持っていらっしゃらない方がいらっしゃったらあちらはスクリーンをご覧
下さい
あそこに目ている服実像は今会場の中のカメラで作り出されている服実像です
はい
大丈夫でしょうか
はいありがとうございます
そしてこの服実像がどのように心霊写真として表れているかをご説明します
私たちは車体に向かっていつもカメラを向けていますよね
その時に先ほどの実像のように取材から出た光がレンズを通してスクリーン上に結像し
ますですが先ほどの航路図のように
福実像はレンズをすぐ後方にも現れるんです
そしてカメラのピントを調整するためなのにレンズをより近く
レンズとスクリーンの距離が近くなったときこの服地後方の服実像が画面上に現れる
つまりスクリーンに乗るよって心霊写真が作られているんです
これで一部の心霊写真は証明することができます
そして私たちはこの研究を生物分野に応用させました
というのもある学会で人間の眼でも服実像が見えますかというご質問を頂いたからです
回答から来たお答えすると見ることはできません
じゃあ人間の目によく似た構造を持つ昆虫の嘆願はどうだろう
そういった疑問から私たちはこの研究にさん昆虫の嘆願を使いました
そして今回単勝に対象にした昆虫はこちらの3つです
アブラゼミオオスズメ町トノサマバッタの3州を使いました
そしてここで嘆願とは何かご説明します
昆虫はよく見る
人間のような目のような大きなものは2つ複眼というものを持っています
しかしそれとは別に頭の上部の方にレンズ眼レンズができている単眼というものがあり
ます
このスライドの中では赤い丸で囲んである部分が嘆願です
そして私たちは最終者さん昆虫もマイナス60度で冷凍し凍結ミクロトームと呼ばれる
機器を用いて10マイクロメートルずスライスしていきました
それを染色液で染色し
レンズがどれだけ曲がっているかといった曲率半径
レンズの厚みそして網膜までの位置を特定します
これらのデータを
以前導出していた式に代入することによってそしてフッ設立 n
も考慮することによって昆虫の端団においてどこに吹く実像が表れているのかという
ものを導出しました
今回はオオスズメバチの嘆願モデルを使ってご説明します
左側に見える白いものがオオスズメバチの嘆願です
そして丸倉底部分が網膜です
実は昆虫は園主の状態つまり人間ねぇトロンが老眼のような状態なんです
だから昆虫の嘆願の中では実像は
網膜からもっともっと遠いところに結像しています
ですが今回の調査によって服実像は
実像よりもより網膜に近い位置に結像していることが分かりました
そしてこの結果はアブラゼミトノサマバッタなどの他のすべての昆虫においても手術増
より
網膜に近い位置に吹く事実をが出現していることが分かりました
このことから私たちは
昆虫が吹く実像を見ている可能性を示唆することができたんです
そしてこの研究は次のような例に応用することができます
例えば広角レンズに応用できるんです
福実像はより広いで範囲で現れることができます
だからより広範囲を捉える監視カメラであったり天体の動きを観測する装置に応用する
ことが考えられています
これが私たちの研究です
この研究をここまで持ってくるのに6年半
22名の生徒そして顧問の先生が何度も何度も挑戦を積み重ねてきました
そして私たちはこの稽古の成果を持って今年の5月アメリカのピッツバーグで行われた
インテル is という大会に参加してしまうきました
intel isef とは国際学生科学技術フェアという
という大会で society for 3 s 園 the public という
ところが主催しています
毎年5月にアメリカの都市で開催されており今回の2018年の大会は81の国や地域
から
1792名の学生が参加しました
賞金総額400万ドル以上
スポンサー60以上も付くまさに世界規模の大会です
そこで私たちは
物理天文学部門に出展しました
哀切では日本の大会とは少し異なりその研究は社会のためにどう役に立つの
どれぐらいのお金を生み出せるのといった興行的な質問がとたくさん飛び交いました
私たちの研究は基礎研究に入るのでそういった質問に答えるのは少し難しかったですが
宇土高校から入った3人の皆で一緒に頑張って何とかその質問乗り切ることができまし
た
そして4位というブランドアワード4位
物理天文学部門で4位という素晴らしい成績を得ることができました
表彰式で名前を奪い届き
私がステージの上から見た景色はきっと私は一生忘れることができないと思います
だからそんなアメリカの舞台にもう一度立ちたいと思ったんです
小さい時から保育士になるのが夢でした
そして中3の夏に科学に目覚めましたその二つを学べる環境がアメリカにはあります
そしてもう一つ私にはやらなければならないことがあるんです
i 世二に参加するとこのような金のメダルをもらえます
でもそしてこの金のメダルを左胸に掲げて生徒たちは審査に臨みます
でも周りを見てみると少し違ったんです
i 世二には4年連続で参加している生徒がたくさんいます
今回私たちが参加者最下位でも1位の優勝したところは優勝した学生
オーストラリアの学生は左胸にたくさんのメダルをつけていました
そして
今回のアイスにアメリカに次いで正答を送り込んできたのは韓国の47名です中国や
台湾のファイターも見られます
しかし日本の学生は今回23名しか参加していません
実はもほとんどが1回しか参加できないんです
こんなことで科学の世界で戦っていけるんでしょうか
若者がこんな若者の時点で負けていていいんでしょうか
だから私は後輩たちに何度も何度もチャレンジできる環境を作りたいんです
そして私たちのリベンジをしてほしいんです
だから私はアメリカの大学で
教育政策と科学を学びたいと思っています
こう言うと皆さんにはビッグマウスに見えるかもしれません
でも私はそれでいいんです
なぜなら私が中3の時憧れていた先輩も私にはビッグマウスに見えました
でも彼女の夢は実際にかなったんですから
ありがとうございます